in this video we're going to be looking
at Star Wars zombies yep zombies these
creatures have appeared in both Canon
and Legend stories of Star Wars and they
are as terrifying as you can imagine in
this video we'll explore every time
zombies have appeared in Star Wars and
how they were created let's start with
the zombies that have shown up in Canon
titles the first time we saw zombies in
Star Wars was in the animated series The
Clone Wars in the season 2 episode
Legacy of Terror in this episode Anakin
Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi discovered
that the geonosians have a secret weapon
brain worms that reanimate and control
dead bodies these worms can also infect
living hosts turning them into mindless
slaves of the geonosian hive mind the
Jedi have to fight their way through
hordes of zombie geonosians and clones
and eventually destroy the queen of the
hive mind to stop them the second time
we saw zombies in Star Wars Canon was in
the season 4 episode Massacre of the
Clone Wars in this episode General
Grievous invades the plan of damir home
of the night sisters a clan of force
wielding Dark Side witches the night
sisters use their magic to raise their
dead sisters as zombies and send them to
to attack Grievous and his droid army
the zombie night sisters are fast and
agile and can use their claws and teeth
to rip apart their enemies however they
are no match for grievous' Firepower and
he eventually wipes out the night
sisters the third time we saw zombies in
Star Wars cannon was in the video game
Star Wars Jedi Fallen order in this game
the protagonist cestus encounters a
night sister named Marin on damir who is
the last survivor of Grievous's attack
Marin uses her magic to raise more
zombie night sisters as well as zombie
night brothers who are male counterparts
of the night sisters Cal has to fight
his way through the undead horde until
he reaches Marin and convinces her to
join him the fourth time we saw zombies
in Star Wars cannon was in the
liveaction series Ahsoka in the season 1
finale in this episode Ahsoka Tano faces
off against Grand Admiral Thon who has a
secret weapon night Troopers these are
storm troopers who have been resurrected
by nightsister Magic using a chant of
Resurrection the night Troopers are
loyal to thraw and have enhanced
strength and durability Ahsoka and her
allies have to fight the night Troopers
while also trying to stop thraw from
returning to their home Galaxy now let's
move on to the Legends zombies the first
time we saw zombies in Star Wars Legends
was in the 2009 novel death Troopers by
Joe shriberg this novel is set before A
New Hope and follows a group of
survivors on an imperial prison barge
that encounters a Derick Star Destroyer
the Star Destroyer is infested with the
bioweapon called project Blackwing or
the sickness which was created by Sith
Alchemy the sickness kills anyone
exposed to it and then reanimates them
as flesh eting zombies the survivors
have to escape from the zombie infested
ship while also dealing with some Amar
faces Han Solo and Chewbacca the second
time we saw zombies in Star Wars Legends
was in the 2010 novel red Harvest also
by Joe Sher this novel is set during the
Old Republic era and follows a group of
Jedi and Sith who are trapped in a Sith
Academy that's overrun by zombies the
zombies are created by a Sith Lord named
Darth scabas who uses an ancient Sith
artifact called The muracami Orchid to
create a virus that turns living beings
into Undead servants the third time we
saw zombies in Star Wars Legends was in
the 2011 video game Star Wars the Old
Republic in this game players can
encounter several types of zombies on
different planets for example on taus
there are rat ghouls Sith engineered
mutant creatures made by The Sith Lord
Carnes Moore that can infect other
beings with their bite or scratch on Bel
Salis there are corrupted eShop an
ancient alien species with Savage
violent tendencies that cared only for
the destruction of all other races and
were experimented on by the ricotta
Empire on the planet Voss there are
gormac zombies which are gormac warriors
that were killed by the Vos Mystics and
then reanimated by Sith sorcery whether
they created by worms magic bioweapons
or viruses zombies have appeared in Star
Wars many times and they are always a
threat to be reckoned with so what do
you think of zombies in Star Wars let me
know in the comments below and don't
forget to like And subscribe or check
out the video on your screen for some
more of my content